Cool. Okay, let's get on with it. So, hi
everyone. My name is Elan. I'm on the
developer experience team at OpenAI. Um,
unfortunately, I can't be there in
person as much as I would love to. I'm
in a wedding in Costa Rica um which is
happening later today. So, I just wanted
to take this opportunity to just talk
through um one of my favorite concepts
in maybe all of like AI and language
models. So, uh title of this talk is
function calling is all you need. It's a
talk workshop. There's going to be um a
lot of coding. Please save your
questions. No, I'm kidding. Like just
interrupt at any point. Uh we have a
Slack. Send them here. Um yeah, just
send them at any point. Uh and if you
want to like unmute yourself and or
raise your hand, I'll call you off like
as we go. The idea is to keep this super
super dynamic. Um since we have a bit of
time, um I'll be fielding a lot of like
questions and requests and trying to be
coding as much as
possible. So yeah, this talk is going to
need some lecturing uh a lot of coding
from scratch and then some debugging
hopefully not a lot. Uh so this is a
little bit of what the uh workshop is
going to look like. We're going to go
over a little brief history of the tool
formers of of I'm sorry of function
calling. Um then do a little crash
course on function calling. Um talk
about just agents how they're just
loops. How rag workflows and more are
just function calls delegation and
asynchrony. couple random things I found
and then we're going to do a Q&A. Um, if
you just want to see like the meat of
it, this is pretty much it. We're going
to do like this is everything I want to
talk about uh and everything that we're
going to implement. So, this is uh just
a little bit
upfront. Great. So, a little history.
Um, if we look at the abstractions and
sort of patterns that we managed to do
with language models, it started as text
completion, right? like the original GPT
uh and the GPT2 and the GPT3 were all
just base models where you gave them
some input text. Um and then they would
just continue the sentence. Um this was
at the time really really like
interesting. This was the first time we
were able to do like very like uh
English sounding like real sounding
language. Um but getting it to follow
instructions was pretty hard. So if any
of you were testing this back then you
might remember how setting up a chatbot
was um non-trivial, right? you had to
like get it to answer questions. But if
you just say like, you know, what is the
best way to uh get to the like park or
something, it would continue
like like what is the best way to get to
the park? Um that is what Sally said
yesterday, right? And you wouldn't
actually get a a response. Um so you had
to like structure it in a way where you
would say like this is the question,
this is the answer question answer few
shot and then give it. Um then they
introduced uh I think this was actually
us. We introduced uh function um
instruction following with uh instruct
GPT. Now you could give it some input uh
and it would actually do what you're
asking as opposed to just completing. Um
finally we started to introduce this
notion of like users and assistants and
roles. Um and this was all done through
through post training where you actually
gain these personas. Um and then finally
uh we we eventually landed on this like
you can give it additional tools um in
order to do like external um any like
interact with external states. So this
is what the previous playground used to
look like. But as you can see there's no
chat. This is just like a window and
it'll complete. Now looking over at like
the original papers which is pretty
interesting. Um, one of the first times
that we actually started to do this like
function calling was through this web
GPT um, which was this uh, version of
GPT3 that we trained to be able to um,
Elan, I have to cut in here a little
bit. We got the Zoom working. Yay.
Sweet. Um, all right. We're going to cut
over in the audio. So, can everyone hear
Elon when he speaks? Elon, say
something. Hello. Hi, everyone.
Hello. Hello.
How's it going? Okay. So, so we're going
to cut over a little bit in terms of
like um people having their own personal
audio situation going on. So, you can
mute your machine. You should be able to
hear it on the room uh audio, whatever
you want to do, but you can also
obviously connect. But, uh yeah, now we
have him on the big screen. So, okay.
Yeah. Uh let's let's keep going for a
bit. I I'll cut in again if there's
audio issues or maybe you want to say
some test words.
Uh, you're all great. Thank you for
coming. Can we bump up the audio?
Where's the guy?
[Laughter]
It's not a conference if you don't have
AV issues. Okay. Uh, it's it's still too
soft. We can't we can't hear you. Um,
I'm going to try and bump up the audio.
I'm so sorry.
I'll put up a more interesting slide in
the meantime. You guys can look at this
while we figure this out.
Where's Where's the video?
Hey. Um,
so anybody got uh good jokes?
Maybe I always find a joke.
It's always the same
one. I think it's uh What is it? Why did
the No, I had it. I had it here. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. There we
go. Why can't you trust an atom? Yeah,
because they make up everything.
These are all real, by the way. And for
for those who like have a keen eye, the
first one is like actually from the GPT2
paper. Um we like gave the model this
like description of like unicorns in the
Andes Mountains. And that was like the
big like first time that it was like
doing multi- paragraph completion like
continuations that referenced earlier
parts of the
conversation. It's cool stuff. It's cool
history. Can you guys hear me?
I feel like some people are having a
great time. Some people don't know
what's going on. Can like I don't know.
Am I good to keep going or should I keep
waiting? Uh I think I think you're good.
Okay, great. Great. I do think this is
the vibe of the whole talk by the way.
There's it doesn't get more structured
from here. Um okay, so as I was saying,
uh we did like this web GPT paper. Um,
essentially we trained a GPT3 version of
the model uh or like a GP3 model to be
able to use this like this very specific
set of functions um to do web search.
And this was like back in 2021. So
really we had like webg a long time ago.
Um but this is like one of the first
times or maybe the first time that like
we were having like it's not just
generating text but it's generating
actions and then we're parsing those
actions and then introducing it back
into context so it can use the responses
itself. Um, and how we trained it there,
um, there's like these these like, you
know, clever ways of like we we
essentially gave people, uh, an
interface and let them do the searching.
Um, and then I think we took it like
Reddit um, yeah, explain like five. Um,
and then just like had people complete
tasks and they could use these commands.
And so we taught the model and this was
GPT3, right? Um, how to essentially
imitate users behavior and then produce
responses that were preferred. Um and
and this was pretty cool like this is
how you we like start to saw um to see
like this uh this use of like structured
like actions essentially. So but this
was very specific right we were training
like very specific um tools. So then you
might be familiar with this paper. This
was from Meta at the time. Um where they
essentially had a way to teach the
models how to use any tools. Um and they
taught like they they used a few tools.
I think it was like QA calculator. Um
what was this like translation? Um
couple other couple other tools. But um
it was actually a pretty clever way
where they like looked at the log props
at each spot to like see where it was
like best suited to like retroactively
put in a function call given some like
completion. Um so here we can see a few
examples like um essentially it's like
if you have a calculator call if you
insert a calculator call that like you
know it'll it'll insert the um the
actual call to the calculator which then
you know you're pretty familiar at this
point will get the answer if you insert
it in the right spot in the sentence it
actually reduces the perplexity of the
sentence. Um, and so they didn't
actually have a lot of human-labeled
examples or I think it was just a few,
but it was uh really cool because it was
this way of like um it could learn to
use uh any of these tools through this
like crazy like log props technique.
Um and it was uh I was pretty excited
when I saw this paper. Now this is like
how it learns to use any of these tools.
Um, but then finally, uh, in June of
2023, uh, OpenAI launched just general
function calling where we essentially
like pre-trained it to be able to use
these tools or actually post-trained it
to be able to use, uh, tools. So now you
don't actually have to like give it like
you can give it examples, but uh, we
just showed it like this like syntax in
with functions that we still use today
and it's just able to call functions. So
this is a brief history of of function
calling. Um, and my I guess my argument
is this is really most of what you need
for all the exciting stuff that's
happening today. Um, there's there's
obviously like additional like systems
you can use and like um more post
training you can do, but fundamentally
like functions are so so so powerful and
we're going to look at a few cases
today. Um, I'm going to try to keep an
eye on questions, but
um
yeah. Okay, I think you're good so far.
Cool. Cool. So, let's do a super quick
crash course on function calling. Uh,
two main purposes and I'm ripping a lot
of this from the docs. So, um, there the
fetching data, right? Reading APIs,
retrieval, memory, or taking action, any
APIs you can use to write, managing
application state, which is actually
pretty overloaded. That can be like UI,
front end, backend, whatever you want.
And then workflow actions, which is um
any like multi-step processes or even
like meta actions like switching its own
prompt or like loading in different
tools or like handing off a
conversation, right? Um so this is also
a diagram straight from the docs, but um
I'll quickly brush past this. I'm going
to assume like most people have at least
seen this, but here it is. It's uh you
you essentially tell the model which
functions you you want it to be able to
use. Um and you also provide like
whatever the user input is. Um the f the
model tells you what it wants to do with
that function but it doesn't actually do
it. This is one of the like a big
sticking point function calling. It
doesn't actually use the function
itself. It tells you like it tells you
the intent of what it wants to do with a
function. You are then responsible for
parsing that, executing the code, doing
whatever you want with it and then
providing the result back to the model
and then the model can use that respon
like result in uh in the generation. Uh
take a look at a quick question
here. Oh no, it's just it's just swings.
Okay, cool. Um these are just a few uh
best practices. This is all taken from
the docs as well. Um you want to write
clear functions. An important one is you
got to apply software engineering best
practices when you write these
functions. So, um, you know what? Maybe
I'll pull up the docs for
this.
Um, so there's a lot of big text, but
essentially,
um, this is a lot of value here. I tried
to pack as much like useful information
here as I could, so I'm going to quickly
go over it, right? Um, you had to
explain the purpose of each parameter,
use a system prompt, and include
examples. That's, you know, pretty
pretty like not non-controversial. Um,
software engineering best practices is a
little bit uh more interesting, right?
You got to make functions obviously
intuitive and they got to follow the
function of lease principle. Um, like if
you give this to a person and they don't
know how to use it, then the model might
not either, right? Models are getting
smarter than us, but still you got to
make it uh got to make it easy. Um, also
you got to use enums and object
structure to make sure that like you are
not letting the model make invalid
calls, right? Um like here you you have
this like toggle light uh um function
that takes in like two two boolean
params and like obviously like this is
pretty wrong but um there's actually
many many more like subtle cases where
um like the you can like you're letting
it represent invalid states.
Um okay, still no questions. It's Swixs.
Okay. Um, great. And then there's Sorry,
there are a couple questions in the
professor convers. I see. I see.
Um, here maybe let me see if I can pull
up the
Slack. Okie
dokie. Between functions and tools in my
opinion. Hey Sam. Yes. Um I I think
we've all been kind of like gravitating
toward functions and tools as like the
two main ways. Originally it was just
functions. Tools was like later we
renamed it. Um I think now uh and the
way that I tried to specify in the docs
is functions are like the the raw
function calling right like you provide
an interface and you're responsible for
executing the code. um tools and this is
sort of how we treat it in our API is a
superset of functions. Tools include
functions but it also includes things
like um code interpreter or file search
or any of these like um like hosted
solutions. I'd say this is not be like
end all beall definition but this is a
definition that we've adopted right
there's like tools which are like hosted
tools uh including functions and then
functions as a subset. Cool. Maybe we
can just jump into it. Um, if people
have questions on this, happy to happy
to feel them as well. But I kind of want
to get coding. Okay. Uh, when you start
to approach dozens or hundreds of
functions, what technically should we
apply in order to effectively tool
call permissions is one technique. Okay,
interesting. And then question two, when
you require one tool to provide inputs
to another, I have seen tools become
layered. How should a reasoner hardcode?
Great. Okay, these are actually great
questions. And um I think to to answer
them, I might I might like do a little
hack and like uh use some existing uh
code. I'm going to use swarm for a
little bit of this um because it does
some nice function calling. Actually,
no, you know what? I'm going to get to
these fun uh in a second. Um let's just
go straight into the uh and as always,
we should start from the docs.
Uh, cool. Uh, so this is where I always
step in. Can you zoom in on screen every
single page? Yeah. Yeah. Bigger.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. I always do. Yeah.
Yeah. No, this is a good call out. Uh
and then I think
the terminal
here should be good.
Okay, sweet. Uh we have we have a
function. Great. Um and
then just run
it and we have uh the function call.
Right now we're not handling it yet. So,
this is where like I might skip ahead a
little bit um and start doing some of
the like agentic stuff. But first, uh
first off, uh we we got to have a right
like you know you you I can sort of hear
myself. Um I think so. There we go.
Perfect. Okay. So um I think the idea
here is like let's make a very very very
simple like uh input loop
like let's do uh while you also light
mode
light mode
Jesus okay
sure I'm just very experienced at this
we go
well that's the least painful this is
good right this works
Yeah. Oh, my poor eyes.
Um, actually, maybe I I I can't quite
see the room, but show of hands, like,
who has used or implemented function
calling in the past, and someone's going
to have to gauge this for
me. Okay, it's everyone. Great. I'm
going to skip ahead a little. There's
like 10
20% 20% that hasn't done it. Okay, 103%.
Um the important part that you have to
know is you can define the function um
schema, right? Then the tool will
specify what you want. And then in this
case, you know, if I have like
a get weather tool. Actually, I'm going
to grab this from the docs as well. When
in doubt, just go to the docs. You know,
it's always good.
So, step one. No, this is all node.
Yeah. And this will be useful for later
too.
Um, step one, call the
function. Step
two, execute your code. Right? So here
what we're doing is we're taking we're
parsing out what the what the function
told us. We're parsing out the args and
then we're calling this get weather
function which we don't have yet. Um,
but conveniently it's up here, right? So
we have it up here. get weather
requests and then the last step is we
provide the result back to the model. Um
uh provide the result back to the model
and then ask for a completion. Right? So
just in order specify the tools, call it
the first time, get the tool calls,
parse them out, call the function,
append and do that. Right? So if we do
that and we just add maybe
like add I'm going to do this by
hand. Why not? Yeah. So I'll print the
completion here sort of by hand and then
print the last
completion. Then what we can see is
we'll get the first one that includes a
tool call. It'll call the actual
temperature uh call the weather API and
then we'll get a
response and then it says the current
temperature in Paris is something I
can't see it because of Zoom. Um cool.
So this is like the very very basic
setup for a function calling. Let's take
a step forward. So this is an agent uh
very very very basic implementation of
an agent um that I'm going to go through
really really quickly cuz we're going to
start using it. This is very familiar to
what you'll see in Swarm or any of the
other like like basic frameworks. Um but
the idea here is in uh as you can see
like in the original one essentially
like when it had a tool call I wanted to
provide it back. So what I do here is
while like just keep looping and this is
like the very famous like agents are a
loop. This is this is that loop.
Um, specify the
tools, call the model, get the message,
print it out, handle the tool calls,
append it, and once we have no more tool
calls, break. This is the whole loop. I
called it run full turn in my head. One
turn is just like you let the model do
everything. Um, and then we have this
like execute tool call, yada yada,
whatever. Um, so now we can use this.
So
agents
py did I export
it. There we go.
I love it. Okay, so now we're just going
to specify
one. Um, you know what? Yeah, we um and
we'll we'll do it we'll do it with a
with a simple
loop. So we have this that and we have
this. Okay. So now we can just do Asians
run full turn. The one other thing that
I'm adding here that I didn't show is um
this simple utils
uh that defines this very very very
useful function. So functions to schema
essentially takes in a raw python object
function and then provides it into the
uh like correct schema um so that you
can just define functions directly and
this is the same thing that we have in
swarm and there's an a few other
frameworks now as well um so as an
example we can do like you know get
weather and I'm just going to like you
know return
20 like
degrees Celsius
Right. I'll do that
here. Then I'll have my
messages and
messages. Is this emergency reference? I
think it is.
What did I call
it? Oh. Oh.
Oh, I see. This is not part of
the Asian
class.
Cool. So, it called the weather, printed
it out, uh, gave us a nice little
completion. Um, this is essentially what
we want to see. If I say, um, and then I
can just keep keep going, right? So, we
we we have this basic um basic loop. Um,
now let's get back to the presentation
real quick. That was like a very very
immediate crash course. Now let's let's
get interesting. Um and and just for
convenience, I'm going to like pivot to
the swarm implementation. Um the main
reason being it's pretty much the same.
Um except we have like some convenient
uh like looping tools. So
uh swine imports
agents and then
There we go. So now we can
do a simple agent and run a demo loop.
And let's see this work.
Um we have this very basic setup. Let's
do everything now. So
um another show of hands. How who here
has implemented uh
rag? Okay. What about
memory? Okay. Fewer. And then what about
like you know multi multi-step things
and
workflows? Cool.
Um how about this? There's a lot of
stuff we could talk about, but I want to
keep this valuable to you all. Out of
this list, can you like just type in the
Slack what you wanna what you want to
see and I can just change the order in
which we'll cover this. Um because
they're pretty they're pretty
interchangeable. We can we can build up.
Um but essentially there's there's more
interesting
things later on, but I want to make sure
we we can build up to them. So, just uh
if you can pull up the Slack and just
dump in, you know, what you're
interested in
seeing. Okay. Lots of memory. I see.
Um function generation from the docs.
Delegation async. Okay.
build
delegation and random cool stuff. I will
get to the random cool stuff.
Um, okie dokie. Back to light mode. Um,
yeah, let's start with like a very very
basic form of memory, right?
Um, how would we how do we do this?
Let's see. Honestly, like we can have
um just a list, right? Memory can just
be this list. And I'm going to implement
this similar to how it's done in
chatbt. Um but ju just to show like I
think the whole point of this talk is
like this workshop is like doing things
from first principles and just really
removing the complexity. I think there's
like a lot of like not fake complexity
but like added complexity on things that
like doesn't really need to be there a
lot of the time. like concepts are a lot
more simple and it's all about function
calling. So,
uh we can do you know add like add to
memory and I'll append it and then get
memory. Uh like this is super super
simple.
Um is this is this good enough? Let's
see. Maybe maybe. And so what we can do
is give it the tools. Let's see and then
what when will we want to use them?
Let's say you like I can just say so
this comment is going to be used as the
uh string uh as the as the description
in the function. So you can say like you
know like when the user tells you
something like
factual
about
themselves their life
or I can't see anything okay or
their
preferences call this function
um memory. Um and we'll add a couple
more cool things like
expiration, which is one that I've kind
of wanted to add for a while. So, you
know, for now, let's say false
um memory.append
uh think
And then we
have I guess what we call it uh you know
memory
text and we can say you know keep the
memory text short size. Great. Cursor
knows what I
want. And then we can just return maybe
like this is a super super super naive
implementation. Um, but now, uh, when we
start off, I guess we could
even start off with
[Music]
a I mean, this is going to be kind of
hacky, but I can just like um in your
first
turn always call get memory. This is not
uh great. It's just because of the demo
loop. But maybe I'll break I'll break
the demo loop out so we can actually do
this by hand. But
so how how could we prove this?
Um maybe let's say like you know write
this memory bank or
like keep this memory bank in a local
file JSON file read it in
at
beginning and write it out at every
Nice. Okay, I trust this. Shall we test
it out? So,
wait, someone
uh Okay, we got the memory memory. Can
any can anyone see any
bugs? Because we're about to test this
out. So, we got the loop. It's going to
call it um and maybe like
let's
memory. Okay. Sure. Yeah. Let's try it.
Let's try it out. See what
happens. So,
hi. Did I not give it the functions?
Is it hallucinating
this? Oh yes, because I think we called
it
functions.
Hi. There we go. Okay, so called get
memory. There's nothing there. I can
just say like um I am 6 feet tall
despite what people think.
Uh, cool.
Uh, so now let's just check, right? It
should have written this out. There we
go. So now we have it in the memory
bank. So now I can actually uh end this,
right? And then be like, you know, uh,
how tall am
I? Tada. We've implemented memory,
right? There's a Yes, I'll take a clap.
I saw Louis Lewis, you're like my proxy
for the Luis uh Luis Costa, you're my
proxy for the audience. You're like the
only person I can really see. So, please
don't uh turn off your camera. Um,
amazing. Now, we can do more interesting
things, right? We can
uh if we want do a little bit like smart
querying uh where instead of just like
loading in all of the memory, um we can
like do a little bit of like retrieval
uh to load in the right ones. um and use
like semantic similarity or use some
kind of search.
Um I I could try to implement that. Um
that might take a little bit longer but
not that long. But I do want to pause
here. See like given this and like this
is going to be the style of things that
we do like what um what do we want to
see next? I can just keep going with
this example. I can pivot. Uh it could
be fun just to keep building on this.
See how far we can
get. Let's see.
uh delegation async have it chat and
work in the background. We'll get there.
We'll get there. I got that working this
morning on Python because I didn't want
to switch to to Node yet. Uh delegation
async.
Okay. Let's get into delegation
then.
So, there's a few different ways we can
do this. I'm actually going to leave the
memory and we're just going to keep
building in this on this on this agent.
Uh, and I am using the swarm agent just
cuz I didn't want to debug the one that
I implemented. But like if we actually
look at what this is, um,
like it is very very very simple. And
then the like run demo loop itself is
like uh just printing out
messages. Um, and what it's doing is
like appending client.run whatever. And
like if we look at this client.run run.
Um, if it doesn't stream, it essentially
does exactly what we did before, like
keeps looping, get the completion, throw
the messages in,
uh, append them, handle responses, etc.
There's a couple more things around
context and handoffs that we like don't
don't really have to look at today. Um,
but we
can.
So, cool, we have memory. Let's do
delegation.
Um, so there's a couple ways we can do
this, right? Um,
there's if you think of like functions
and agents and and everything you can,
um, maybe I'll skip to this
slide. Skip skip skip
skip. These are like a few of the forms
of like agents on delegation that people
might be familiar with. We have
handoffs, which is like the swarm style.
You take a conversation and fully swap
it to a different agent. Um, and what
that means is just like replacing the
system prompt, replacing the tools. Um,
you can have nested calls which are the
easiest to implement and like often
somewhat overlooked. Um, and then you
can have manager tasks that's more
async. Uh, we will get to that today.
So, let's do a very basic one, right?
Let's say I want to do like
um maybe let's give it a chance to like
call a bigger model to do a harder task,
right? So we can say like you know uh I
can delegate to smarter
model and and I'm going to give like
task
description.
[Laughter]
Um so I'm laughing because this is
saying like it's just going to make it
smarter by telling it to be smarter.
That's not despite how well that would
work. Usually we're not going to do
that. So we're we can just make an API
request directly. Actually, let's just
do that. Let's just do that. So um let's
do from OpenI client. And here we could
do client chat completions create. Let's
call
01.
Um I won't provide a system message. I
think that's okay. content is the
description. Look at that. And we did
it. So now
um man, I love cursor. Okay, did
everyone catch all of that? By the way,
all we did was like implement this this
function that calls opening API and then
here. So now I can say like uh so now I
can add a bit of a description here. I'm
like like uh if you know if the user has
to like
um I don't know do
something like that seems difficult or
says it's hard use this
instead
of
try uh and it infers you know how to use
this based on like the fact that I
called it test description. It's, you
know, so let's give this a shot.
Hi. Um, let's see. Uh, you know, give me
a poem
about, I don't know, dogs and the earth
where
each
other
starts with the next letter.
Yeah, it might just try it because I
know GPD4 can do a variation of this,
but um Oh, it's giving it a shot. Okay.
Let's see if it gets it
right. Okay. I don't have
uh I don't have the patience. Let's
say answer briefly. one subkins max.
Okay, great. And
then
to you know uh write a haik coup. There
we go. It's shorts where each other word
starts with the next letter of the
alphabet and ends with the previous
letter of the alphabet. I don't know.
You guys want to try this while this
does
it? Is it around? Did I lose Did I lose
something? Let's
see.
Hi.
Okay, you
there? Cool.
Um, did I not copy it? Oh no. Okay. Uh,
give me
a thank
you. Now make sure each word starts
with letter of
the alphabet starting with
a and each word ends with the previous
letter.
But this is
hard. Okay. So it should be making the
function
call. Oh, I see. I see. I see. Okay. So
I'm only printing the function call when
it returns. So that's probably why we're
waiting so long here. Um but this is
actually a really good uh example of
like okay we are doing um this like task
delegation technically and like it is
happening in the background and I'm
going to give this a sec to figure this
out. Um but like this is obviously a bad
experience right like you don't want to
be waiting here. You essentially want to
keep doing other stuff. So wow it's
still not still not back. We'll we'll
we'll we'll let it figure it out.
Um, so maybe let's skip straight to
async. Um, we're
actually got like both more and less
time than I thought. So I don't let this
keep turning away. Um, now let's think
about this for a sec, right? If we want
to do something async, it means that
like what do we want to happen? There we
go. So call the model da ya yada buzz
breezy whispered. Is this correct? I
don't know.
Wow. Yeah, this
is sort of
correct. What did it say?
Note. Great. Great. So, it it did
something, right? Um and it did
something that 40 probably could not
have, which is great. That's delegation,
but we were just sitting there waiting
for it.
Um so, let's try doing this async.
Now, I I I I actually want everyone to
like kind of just stop and think like
how would you implement this um in terms
of like what behavior do you want? And
maybe I want to see people like drop
this in the Slack. Just like take a
couple minutes um and like drop in the
Slack like a proposal for how you would
want to do
this and then I might just pick one or
we'll like talk about them.
Let's call 03. Yeah. Not not yet. Not
yet. Yes. Import
async.io definitely feels like uh
important. But I guess the questions are
like you know when we delegate something
uh obviously we want to have this
happening in the background. Um, do we
want like when it finishes, do we want
to be like do we want it to be injected
into the conversation? Do we want it to
give us a response? Um, how many like do
we want to be able to
like interact with tasks that are
running? Um, like do we want to be able
to batch
stuff? I am not setting up a Kafka
cluster. I'm going to give people maybe
a couple more couple more minutes to
just like dump some ideas here. Um,
batch
calls. Yeah, I guess B. But how how
would batch calls work? Maybe Stephania
if you want to add some like detail
there. Just keep working until it
generates a stop
word, right? Okay. Yeah, this is this is
a good idea. JS and set timeout. Yeah,
switching to JS is always a good option
because you already have the event loop
implemented. Smaller model. Smaller
model. Okay, you guys are all suggesting
some good ideas.
Um, but we can actually go simpler,
right? Like like essentially what we
would want and I can implement like the
basic interface of this, where's my
code? Um, is like instead of actually
doing this, right, I can
like
return delegated, right?
response
pending.
Um and then later I can say like you
know check tasks or
something. So this this pattern is
actually one I I quite like a lot where
you
um you call a model it's a function it's
non-blocking and then later you can you
can check up on them. Now the thing is
Python is like single threaded and uh
async is real. Uh it's just a little bit
tricky. Um but let's uh let's give it a
shot. So I do have some async emergency
reference. Now here's the here's the um
thing to notice. when something like for
this to work
correctly, we have this loop that asks
for our input and blocks on our input um
and like is displaying that on the
screen and we don't want to have that be
displayed while it's also like injecting
messages. Um so we essentially want to
separate out like where you give user
input and where actually interesting
stuff happens. So that's what I've done
in this in the basics of this async
folder. So let's take a look at that.
Cool. Um, it looks complicated. It's not
that really that bad. So, um, I'm using
websockets. Essentially, what I'm doing
or sockets, sorry. Essentially, what I'm
doing is,
um, the I have a server and all it does
is
like has a handle user input function,
uh, and a start message processor. Um,
these aren't super important. and we can
take a look at them in a second, but
essentially it just like waits uh on a
specific like uh port and and host. Um
and then I have a client that connects
to that and it just does while true
loops and lets me enter in. Right? So if
we look at what that looks
like, I have it here.
Um so let's go to async. Let me zoom in
here a little bit.
Also, um, while I do this, is there are
there any questions that I've that I've
missed? Um, and if there are, just feel
free to shout them
out. No. Great.
Cool. Covered everything. Everyone is uh
perfectly up to date with everything
I've said. Okay.
Um,
sorry. Okay, so I have this and now I
can say like,
hi, let me show you the the rest of
this. I guess that's probably important.
Uh, D. So we have the server, we have
the client, we also have the a very very
very basic agent imple implementation.
It it looks just like the old one with
the main exception that I'm using async
openai instead.
Um handling tool calls is happening in
parallel. So for each tool call grab it
create the task
um await for them and then just like
await for them all at the same time. Um,
and this just lets it like create a
bunch of tasks that are all going to run
in parallel and once they're done, like
if they if they yield back at any point,
we can keep doing other stuff. Um, by
the way, if these are just like heavy
functions that are doing heavy
processing, it's not going to matter.
The fact that they're in parallel like
in sync, it means that it's still going
to happen one after the other. But if
they're like network calls to other
models, then it's perfect. Um, the
runful turn is the same one. You like
call a model, check to see if there's
any function calls, if not break, return
the response. Um the only difference
here is we're awaiting uh the chat
completion, right? This is the only
difference. And then if we take a look
at our agent handler, we've declared
we've declared our agent like normal,
right? Right now it has no instructions.
It looks very familiar. And this loop is
also pretty familiar. It's like get the
messages. Um here here's the only
difference, right? Um and you'll see why
this matters in a sec. I have a message
Q. Uh and this is will be useful because
we don't want to process multiple
messages in the same conversation at the
same time. Like we want work to happen
at the same time but we don't want um
like multiple generations to happen with
the same history because then you'll get
conflicting like like if two messages if
two functions return and they both need
to be handled uh you essentially while
you want them to happen in parallel the
results should should only come in one
after the other. So we have a cue for
that. Uh and it treats user messages as
well like that. So this is the handle
user input that is being called from the
server. Essentially just throws in a
user input message into the message Q.
Uh and all we're doing here is like
pulling off the queue, run it like you
know uh put put the messages back in the
in the message array uh and then like
sleep, right? This is like just a very
simple uh loop but it does it with
async. So this is what we saw and and it
feels pretty normal right. I can say
like you know my name is Elan and I can
say you know what is my
name. Great.
Um, now this still doesn't exactly
answer how we're going to do things
asynchronously, but it does give us the
space to play with it because now things
are happening async and we can do a few
more delegations that that are actually
async. So, let's start with a, you know,
simple blocking get weather function. I
think I required all functions to be
async here.
Um, yeah. 67 and
70. Uh, and
then skip that and let's test it out.
The only annoying part is we have to
like restart two things now. So, hi. Uh,
what's the
weather? Great. So we can see it called
a function got the response. So far
everything is normal. Now let's do some
delegation stuff. So let's
say let's say we want to call this
function
uh three times for different places. So
we have location
[Music]
um yeah and let's say you know like pick
a random
number from 50 to 80 to
return.
Um, so if we do it in the previous case,
do I still have the round? Yeah, maybe,
maybe
not. Okay. Uh so if we look at okay this
is the non async one. Do we have
weather? We don't have weather. Let's
give it
weather. Let's give it the same weather
function.
Cool.
[Music]
Um we only need random. We don't need
this. And this not
async. Okay. So now we have this weather
function. Let's test this out in the
non- async case. Um I'm going to get rid
of the rest for now.
Um so if I say you know
uh weather in
SF cools it fantastic and now it's like
weather in SF New York uh you know and
the five other cities.
is it's um it's still going to do the
parallel function calling and here it's
fine because they all return
immediately, right? But now let's add
like an artificial weight. So let's
say time do sleep one, right?
Um, cool. So, now what's going to happen
is we're going to ask for that again,
but it's going to take so
long. Weather in five random cities of
your
choosing. So, it's going to take a
while. And the reason is each of these
is having to run um in like one after
the other. There you go. It took like
over five seconds. Now let's do the same
thing here. So the equivalent is um
there's async io
sleep. Someone let me know if I'm doing
this wrong. But um this should emulate
like very very similar behavior.
So if we instead run it
here that's and that's I can say you
know give me the
weather of five random cities of
York. Um we should see it return. Okay.
Okay, so it called all of
them and it got
back because they all happened in
parallel. Um, this is the magic of
async.io, right? Um, anything that can
be
parallelized or I guess scheduled in a
way where where it's non-blocking. Uh,
like sleeps, these sleeps are
non-blocking. Um, essentially we can we
can do and so you can imagine switching
this sleep for like an actual API call.
Um,
so, uh, we can actually do that right
now with 01, right? Like we could call
01 multiple times and they would all run
in parallel. Now, the main problem is
that we're still going to be waiting
back like waiting to to get all of them
together, right? Like like the fact that
it we can run them in parallel means
that like we can have five 10-second
tasks running in parallel. So it'll take
10 seconds, but it's still going to take
10 seconds where I can't talk to the
model. So instead, let's have this
notion of
tasks. There's many ways to do this.
Um, I'm going to do a pattern that I
quite like. So let's do this.
Um let's define a you know create
task. So I have a create task function
that makes a task. Um no and I want to
create like a task
ID and I want to keep it short.
Okay. So now what I've done is I have
this function that makes a random task
ID, sets it, creates it and then calls
like let's say get weather or something.
Um and then it's you know it's
suggesting this check tasks which is the
next thing that I want to do. So the
next one is check tasks. And
so maybe I can just say like check
task, you know, do
for
amazing.
Um, okay. So let's take a moment to to
look at what just happened. We now
create a task with a random ID. We give
back the ID to the model and then later
we can call check task. get that task,
see what the status is, and see if it's
done. Um, so let's like add, I don't
know, 5-second delay
here. And right now, let's just get
weather. So description would be maybe
create task for, you
know, let's
see again this is all like sort of live
coding, so we'll see if it works. I can
say like you know create a task
um and set the description to the to
be San
Francisco. Let's see what
happens. Oh, I didn't give it these
functions. There we go.
Um, let me just check. Cool, cool, cool,
cool. Okay, let's do it
again. Say, you know, create a task
where the location or the
description is
just. So now it creates the task and I
can say hi. And look at that.
It That's not working
correctly. Maybe it was Maybe it just
took a while to respond. Um here, let's
add a longer delay to know for sure. 10
seconds. Let's run it back.
So create a
task with
description se uh
cool. So I can say hello
there. Cool. So it can still respond to
me, right? Um check the
task. So I can still interact with
it and it can check to see if it's not
done. Um, I guess we need to keep
checking to see if it'll work. So, you
know, how about or you know, tell me a
joke. Who would have thought? Who would
have thought? Um, cool. So, now like
check them
again. So, it called the task. It is
done. And we have 78 and sunny. I will
take a clap for that. I want to see
everyone clap. Please clap. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. So,
what you just
saw was uh live asynchronous uh
programming. Uh it's very impressive.
The models can also, you know, do pretty
well. Anyway, here's why this is
interesting. We now have a system where
we can give it tasks and it'll ceue them
up uh and then we can check on their
progress. So, so already we have the
basis for like a really really
interesting thing, right? like this this
thing here right right now it's just get
weather but if we say just like you know
uh
run what do it call like um you know
call
model and
then no but we
want AI
port sync open AI get the client
um I guess we Actually, we can just
leverage the agents. They're already
async. Let's not deal with that again.
Um or whatever. Let's do Let's do it
this way. I did all did it all.
Fantastic. Okay. So, now we can switch
get weather for call
model. And let's try this again. So,
let's give it the same task as
before, which is, you know, hi, just
make sure it's running. um you know
write me a
uh ha coup about I don't know
uh a
coup where the theme is so incredible it
makes me
cry make this a
task okay so it's created the
task and now I can actually say you
Now make a second one but pick a theme
yourself. So now I have this interface
where I can essentially keep chatting
with this and it can essentially spin
off additional tasks. Um you
check check all
tasks. Um let's see what the progress is
like. Look at that. So we have we have
both. Oh, was this a one? That's pretty
fast.
Um, but yeah, so now we have this system
that you can actually just call call
multiple ones. So I'm going to pause
here just open up for questions for a
little bit conversation like other
directions we can take this other ways
we could have done this. Um, but what I
want to look at next is like how can we
do this in a way where we don't actually
have to check um cuz right now like we
don't need these two terminals. This is
just over complicated. Like I think the
the the point of having the second
terminal is so that we can push things
to the conversation without a user
having sent a message first. So I'm
going to pause here. I'm going to field
some questions and then we can get back
to
it. Okay.
Um would you not use generators for
nested tool
calls?
Um, Tom, do you want to I don't know if
there's a mic in the room or like uh
just get get it get it to them. Yeah,
there
is. Also, they can unmute themselves.
Uh, who's your
Uh, sorry.
So, is the one that was uh answering is
So, in the room?
Yeah. Can Can you hear him? No, I can't
hear him.
Hello. Can you hear me in the Zoom?
Yeah, I can hear you now.
I can't hear you
anymore. I don't know if you're saying a
question right now.
No, I was just
wondering if it's possible to treat
agents
objects as a
generator in Python. So you can nest
like you can yield from individual
agents and then yield those tool calls.
Does that make sense? Yeah. Yeah, that
makes sense. This is also very
impressive that you have to do this. I
think someone needs to mute themselves.
I don't know if it's Alain or uh like
someone in the room unmuted and uh put
put this man through through hell. Um
No, it's me. It's me.
Oh, is your laptop
unmuted? I can't hear anyone
anymore. Maybe just speak into your
laptop. Okay, but I'll I'll answer your
original question of like, you know, if
you put um can you like essentially make
agents into generators so that you can
like yield the results as you go? The
answer is yes. And this is actually like
um the right way to do this. The way I'm
doing it now is I'm only exposing the
final response mostly because um
implementing like the the generator gets
a little bit tricky and I don't want to
have to like debug that. Not too much,
but you can essentially just surface
each of the steps, each of the function
calls, each of the everything.
um that would um that would let you
essentially keep track of more agents at
the same time and you could maybe have
like a bit of a flat structure where you
just have multiple agents going yielding
events and then you can essentially see
like which one's coming from where.
Um but I guess the thing is like there
you have to deal with a bit of the
complexity of um handling all the like
like essentially listening to like all
the different events and like uh
associating them back to like a specific
agent and like maybe there is an agent
in the front, maybe there isn't. Um here
the idea is just I have one agent that
I'm interacting with. I'm always just
going to interact with like that one
agent and it's responsible for spinning
off other other ones and like dealing
with dealing with that as well. But you
can absolutely do it the way that you're
saying. And like if you wanted to build
this out like more fully, you probably
would in order to be able to surface
progress. Um, did that answer your
question? I'm now scared to get people's
talking in the room, but I'll just read
them from Slack.
Um, is there any is there any good
design patterns to create projects with
agents? There's like a million. Um, you
know, like I like prototyping with
swarm. Um, I know paidantic AI is also
like a really nice one. I think Sam's
there in the room or around.
Um, there's Yeah, I don't want to
like I don't really use uh any myself
mostly because like you saw it's pretty
simple to implement your own loop. So
that's what I end up doing. I think
usually for every project I either write
my own like it's like I don't know how
many how many lines is this
like like 70 lines and so like depending
what you want you might want more you
might want less and I'm sure there's
good solutions um but like I just have I
could just copy this around um I don't
really like working with too many
dependencies especially for something
that's so lightweight like I I want
granular control um and like except for
example for Swarm I ended up having to
hop in here and like handling specific
kinds of tool calls in certain ways so
that I can do handoffs. Um, which we can
actually look at and we can implement
this without too much trouble. Um, but
yeah, my answer is like there's many you
can choose from. I don't have many I
would recommend personally.
Um, but I I am a I am a fan of of
Pyantic AI. It's pretty cool. I haven't
used it too much, but like the interface
looks nice. Um, it reminds me a lot of
Swarm. The one I use the most for
prototyping is Swarm. I think it's just
cuz it's the one that like I'm most
familiar with. Um, when you have to
start to approach dozens or hundreds of
functions, what techniques should we
apply in order to effectively tool call?
There's there's a few answers there,
right?
Um, you can have multiple agents and
essentially like split up the
responsibilities or like the the
groupings of the functions. Um and so
into into yeah like clusters where you
have like a set of related functions
that are needed for specific tasks and
then you can invoke the correct agent.
Uh and this is where like multi- aent
patterns start to make sense is like
specifically when you have tons and tons
of functions like how do you uh go to
the right ones? If you for some reason
need them all at the same time, uh you
could try fine-tuning. Um in in projects
for OpenAI, I've ended up fine-tuning up
to like hundreds of fun like it was like
120 functions. This was with uh GPT3.5.
So the fact that that works gives me
like pretty high confidence like you can
fine-tune uh smaller models with a lot
of functions and get them to work pretty
well. Um the last one is like some kind
of dynamic function loading where based
on the input or based on the
conversation you load into memory or
like you load into context um the most
likely relevant functions. Um and
there's a few different ways to do this.
You can do this with embeddings. You can
do this with like
um having like a two-step function call.
At that point, you're essentially having
agents. Like if if you call a function
to then load more functions, that's what
a handoff is essentially. So a lot of
these start to look very similar. Um
it's just like how are you loading
multiple different ones? Um okay, for
visioning models, are there tools being
called within the thought text?
Um,
so because we don't expose the thoughts
like the the chain of thought, um,
that's a little bit hard to answer for
for for 01 right now in the API. The
answer is no.
Um, I'm trying to see how much I can say
here. Um, it is something that is
technically possible, right? Like you
can do anything you want with with post
training.
Um, we do not currently allow you to
call functions within the chain of
thought.
Um, so yeah, right now the function
calls happen at the very end. Uh, do you
have any good code examples for router
patterns in these lots of functions
cases? Yeah. So, so my like my answer
there is some one of these. Like if you
really just want to route um then like
the the idea of having like multiple
agents and handing off to one of them is
actually really nice. Um like you can
just define multiple agents each of them
with like multiple functions. Um and
then have the first one have like a we
can actually do this quickly like we
I'll do this in swarm but like I said
you can implement this yourself. Um I
don't actually know who else supports
handoffs the same way Swarm does, but
um essentially here let's start a new
file like
uh
routing.
So see swarm ripple demo loop I can say
like you know triage
equals one and then I can have my other
two. It's like you know maybe I have
like some collection of like um you can
call them an agent but I can also just
call them yeah like uh what it be like
you know uh
email
functions
agent and you can have like you know
like send
email check email I don't know what else
does cursor want me to write
there. Um, cool. We have these two and
then we can do like maybe we have the
emails and then we have a calendar. I
don't know. So make like
create
event can do like calendar. I'm just
going to say like you know finish what
I'm doing update the prompts and the
tools. I'm lazy. So let's see what uh
let's see what cursor thinks.
Great. So now we have an email functions
agent and a calendar agent. Call them
whatever you want.
Um now like let's pretend that instead
of just having three functions, we have
30 and each one of these has 10 or 15.
Um then like if you maybe give all 30 to
one agent, first of all try it. Like if
that works, amazing, right? you don't
have to deal with the extra complexity.
Um so you don't really want to do
handoffs and stuff until you really
really need to through like evals.
Um but um yeah. So, so and then the
special like kind of functions here is
like you know uh
transfer
to email
agent and I'll
return email agent and then cool. So now
I have my two transfer
functions. Oh. Oh, it did it. Okay,
cool. So I think this should just work
right. So I've defined like the actual
functions and agents that in your case
would be many many more functions. Um
I've defined the transfer functions and
I've given them to the triage agent. So
now if I run
this say hi
um you know I want to send an
email. Cool. So now I'm talking to the
email agent. Now if you want to do like
more you know like transfers
uh this is not delegation. Okay. So
trails assistance um maybe we can tell
the assistance
like you know if you already know what
the user is
asking just call that function right and
this is if you want to have like a case
where you know it still routes you but
it's like a faster two hop so maybe I
can say like what are the functions here
um what are the parameter There's send
email to subject
body. So I can say
like know send an email to
bobgmail.com about
taxes. What was the other
one? Body um saying yo do your
taxes. So it should transfer me to the
email one. And then there we go. It
immediately sends the email. So this
felt like an immediate function call,
but there was a transfer in the way. So
this is kind of an example of like
triaging does work. It's really
convenient to model it with agents and
handoffs. Um I'd say it's the primary
use case for agents and handoffs is just
a glorified triage through uh multiple
functions.
Um yeah, let's see. Let's go back to
questions.
[Music]
Uhhuh. Consider having something like
streamllet grad until you are you
considering having something like
streamlink radio util that allows
porting all interaction functionality
with one
command. I don't think so. I don't know.
Uh what did people answer? There we go.
Sam's in with pantic. So check that out.
Um, how many tool calls can you get in
one
iteration? You like parallel function
calls. I don't think we have hard limits
on either the number of functions or the
number of parallel function calls. How
big a tool library will the models
perform well
with? Super super general rule of thumb
is
like 10 to 20 you shouldn't really pass
over. Um, but like I said, I've gotten
like this was a very specific case where
like it was extremely latency sensitive
and so like we had to have flat like
flat function calling and we did 120
functions with GPT 3.5.
So you can go pretty far um with
fine-tuning, but like I'd say reliably
without without extensive prompting.
Yeah, probably like 10 to 20 like past
that point. You really ask yourself like
what are you trying to do? Like why are
you putting so many functions? Is it
super latency sensitive? Can you split
it up? Like yeah. Um was there a
follow-up
here? Okay. Um rather than tool
calls, I feel like we're moving to
generated code agents, will I soon be
able to supply my tools functions? Ah,
okay, that's a good idea. We should try
that. Um so essentially have something
write its own function and then use it.
Uh yeah, I feel like we can probably How
would we do that? Yeah, we can try to we
can we can find a way to do that. Uh I
I'll do that actually. Let's do right
now. Why not? Let's do right now. Uh
I've never done this before, but I feel
like it shouldn't be too hard. So
um okay. Uh you know, what do we call
this? Like
bootstraps. Okay. So I'll keep using
swarm because I I will use um
handoffs from swarm import
agent. Cool. So now it's always so let's
see we want an agent that writes it own
functions. So
agent was this
one. Um we want it to write its own
functions. So maybe we can have an hand
off to
itself. So we can do you know like
refresh you know what to be refresh
functions. So we can actually return the
same agents.
Um and
then okay is it not declared? Is it
unhappy? Uh yeah it's not defined yet.
Okay. Okay. So now we can define it down
here. Okay. Um
bootstrap bootstraps. Bootstraps. Okay.
So we have this and we want it to write
its own functions. So how are we going
to do this? We wanted to produce
Python. Does anyone have any ideas? uh
if you want to shut them out like make
just pass around the mic while I code
just feel free to I can't I can't read
while you're uh what you write but we
can we can try this. So, um let's say we
want it
to, you know,
um you know, add tool. There we go. And
then let's call this, you know,
Pythonation. Okay. I'm going to do
something very unsafe. So, you know what
would it be? It's like function
obj
equals eval
of Python. Don't do this. Don't do this,
kids.
Um, and then will this work? Is this how
Python works? Sam's there. Uh, okay. So
if I have
this and I eval like you know
def
a does it um okay you know
Um, so I guess it's like uh I want to
write
a write a function that takes a
string representing an implementation of
a Python function and returns the actual
rule Python function as
interpreted. I don't know. Let's see
what it
does. Um, so essentially we want to do
that once we have the function then we
can just append it to the agent and then
we might need to reload it. Uh, so we
can then just return the agent and this
might be
it. This might be it.
So add
tool exec not
eval. Why didn't anyone say that? You
guys can shout
out.
Okay. Okay. So it's
exec and
then what is this
80? I don't
know. Someone save me. Like
uh Hey, there's a couple implementations
you miss. Sorry. Check the flash.
Did someone do this?
Hey. Okay.
It's almost like someone fired. No, no,
no. But this is not Okay. No, but this
is not what I want, right? Like I don't
want it to run it in a subprocess. I
wanted to I wanted to eval like evaluate
the function and then turn it into a is
that Oh, go up. Oh, Sam, of course.
Amazing.
Uh Jesus
Christ. Okay.
um make
it. So the add tool function
uh
evaluates the
implementation and adds it to the tools
similar to
now. Here's a great reference for how
to
Let's And then we want to grab Was this
a good idea? This is a terrible idea. I
hope people are enjoying
this.
Um, okay. Let's see. Um, and let me just
read this because it might not be that
complicated to add in.
So, I can't. Okay, it got in the way.
No, not Zoom. Where's
Slack?
Was this
it? Is this
it? Okay, I'm going to I'm going to put
this on hold for now. It sort of ignored
your implementation, Sam. I'm sorry. Um,
let's see. So if you have parse
function, can I
just do this? Does this
work? Uh, okay. Let's see. I've first
time for everything. Uh, wrong one.
Sub bootstraps. Hi.
Um, add a tool that prints hello when
called
it. Oh, but no, no, no, no. Make it
print it, not just return it.
My heart's pounding. Okay.
Um, so say hello to call
it. Look at that. Look at that. Okay.
So, now we have Yes, I will take a clap
for that. We did this together, guys.
Um, so this is actually a lot less code
than I was expecting, but now we have a
system. Look at that. It's tiny. Um,
that can write its own tools. Um, and so
like maybe we can do something like, you
know, um, what is, you know, like make
yourself a little
calculator. I can't believe this just
worked. Uh, you know what
is 2 * 3
* Can someone check this? Uh, wait,
wait,
wait.
34698.
34698. This is This is crazy. This is
This is so fun. Uh, yeah. I hadn't done
this before. And this is a lot less code
than I thought. Look at this. Look, this
is all you need. I mean, it's this is
super dangerous code. Like,
this this is not good. Don't do this.
But it's fun. Uh, I would put this
squarely in fun things. We can we can
now transition to looking at other fun
things. Um they're definitely not as fun
as this one, I think. Um they're just a
couple of like random things that I
found related to real time since I did
sort of put it in this uh title. So
whatever. Okay, these are the two main
tricks that I that I kind of thought
were pretty cool and you might have
already seen them. Um, one is if you've
ever dealt with like the real time API
um like jumping in uh before you're done
with an idea or like done talking or
something. Um
like what I was thinking is like if if
really what you want is you wanted to
like use the model's own intelligence to
decide if you're done talking or not. Um
and you can treat our VAD like our voice
detection as like a trigger happy
version of that. It's like a it'll
always tell you when maybe the user is
ready to stop talking. But if you want
the model to check, you can have a stay
silent function or something else that
essentially handles the other side of
that where it's like, okay, we're
definitely going to let you know
whenever the user might be done talking,
but then you can actually verify with a
function call. And so this
implementation is like super super
simple. You literally just give you give
the the function
itself to the real time
API and tell it to call it when the user
is not quite done talking. And I'm not
going to try to demo this live. Like
real time demos are tough. Audio is
tough. All that fun stuff's tough. But
um it works like surprisingly well. Uh
if you just describe I I can you can
probably find this tweet but it has the
full prompt but essentially it's like
you can you can like pause you can say
like you know I've been thinking about
and then like stop and like it'll get
triggered call stay silent and then you
can keep talking. Um so pretty pretty
cool uh useful thing. Um and then the
other one is also related to real time
API. And if again if you if you uh are
following me you might have already seen
this but um someone at Devday just like
came up to me and asked me like hey um
is there a way to like make the real
time API talk in like a specific way. Uh
and I was like I don't know let's try
it. And so like we had a demo booth and
I sort of pushed someone out of the demo
booth and grabbed the laptop and I was
like let's just like try try this stuff.
And apparently if you ask the model to
just you give it like a a script and
you're just like, "Hey, read this out
according to these XML tags
um you can have it follow them here. Let
me let me find
um the
original the original one." Yada yada
yada. Sorry, this is I'm not trying
to show you the whole timeline. Where is
it? Okay, this is the stay silent one.
Um, where is it? Where is it? There we
go. Um,
uh, it's impossible that you'll hear
this, right? You guys don't hear
this. Yes. No. Uh, we don't hear it, but
you can hear your computer audio.
Can I
do the thing? I'm I'm I'm actually I'm
not going to try. That's fine.
Um, wait. Can
I same? No, no, no. It's fine. Whatever.
Anyway, um, yeah. So, if if you if you
like give it
like a script like this, um, we didn't
actually train it for this, right? Like
this is just a really nice consequence
of like behavior. It's technically not
function calling. I'm realizing now, but
it's like it's very function
callingesque. It's real time. The title
of this talk does include real time. So,
this is uh this is it. Um I will pause
here. I have so much more I can go
through, but I want to give you guys a
chance to like ask questions, poke
around with some of these ideas. Uh
Swarm is public. You can just try it
out. Um we can also just try creating
other functions. Uh this this is one of
the this is easily one of the coolest
like little programs I've ever made.
Um,
so yeah, let let me see if there's any
other questions of the
Slack.
Uh, it's a room full of people auto
completing make. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay,
let's not do
that. Uh, okay. Revisiting
memory. Let's see. Do you have any
suggestions for trying to enforce
consistency of stored
memories? Identifying inconsistencies
and figure out how to resolve them.
Okay. And then the second part is what
data structures do you suggest for more
structured memory helping enable more
meaningful comparison of objects? I
think I mean this question opens like
you start to go down a path where you
can get as complex as you would like,
right? Like like you can start simple
and you can end up with like an entire
operating system to manage memory,
right? There's like the whole range.
Um, one way to
do off the top of my head like one way I
can think to do this is um when you are
about to store memory do a retrieval
like do search to find similar memories
or like memories that like are
semantically similar um and then do an
explicit check uh with a model to see if
like you know one is like updating or
contradicting another. Right? An example
of this is like you know what is the
latest state of a project right you know
if someone's like is the project like at
some point you say like I'm working on
the project like it's not ready yet and
it saves that and then later you're like
you know I um how like the project's
done now right like those are two
contradicting memories um what you can
do is essentially
uh have a time stamp for them but also
when you are about to store the second
one or any memory
check for similar ones and create like a
direct like essentially
um like node uh pointing from the
original memory to the new one. And so I
guess I guess what I'm thinking is like
that way if anybody
asks and you surface both like you can
keep both in memory and when you do like
retrieval and semantic similarity you
can surface both but essentially you can
present like the whole chain of updates
and so you can just present the last one
if you want or you can present the whole
chain and the model have has some idea
of like you know maybe if you ask it
like um you know how long is this
project delayed because that was the
last you heard about it. But somebody at
some point said, "Oh, it's actually
done."
Um,
like if it raises both and has one with
a later date, you know, maybe. But if
you like if you've already made this
chain explicitly, um, like you can
actually represent that and you can
choose to not show the previous ones. So
that's one idea. Like I said, there's so
many you can like so many ways to do
this. Uh, and and like as soon as I stop
talking, you guys walk out. Someone's
gonna like be like, "Oh, there's
actually this like much easier way that
like this idiot didn't think of." So,
anything you think of probably works.
Um, here's a real time API
prompt. Yeah. Cool. Uh, any other any
other questions about anything? Um, it's
been like an hour and 40 minutes, so
happy to like keep going with random
content. Um, there's a couple demos that
I have that are like demoing some public
repos that we have that you can use.
Um, yeah, but I want to I want to give
anyone a chance to like speak up, say
something if you want, ask
questions.
Um, I I don't see I don't see a lot
happening in I I can't You guys are tiny
on my screen.
Uh, cool. Okay, then I'll pose this to
you. Sorry, what?
Oh, no. Go ahead. It sounds like you're
wrapping up.
Yeah, the the last thing we can do, I
guess, is like either I can um try and
pull up a real time uh demo that shows
how to do the 01 stuff uh in a in a
slightly easier way. Okay, cool. People
want to do that
demo. Okay, let's do it. So, um the
reason I'm a little iffy about it is
because yeah, it's real time. Uh and
those demos are tough to do publicly but
um there is this repo OpenAI um real
time Twilio demo
um that essentially sets up your whole
um like phone calling assistant uh and
it's just works right out of the box. It
walks you through the steps. Um I may
end up sharing a phone publicly. don't
call it during this demo and don't share
it and I will delete it. But um yeah, I
trust you guys. So let's
see. Okay, so it looks like this is
already
running. Oh, I do have it already
running. Okay.
Um Oh, never mind. I I did uh I did make
it all dots. But yeah, essentially this
um this little checklist is like live
updates. So as you set up the account,
as you set up the phone number, as you
set up your local web server, etc.,
it'll like get checked. So setting up
Twilio and Grock and everything has been
one of the most annoying things I've had
to do multiple times um related to the
real time API. So this hopefully makes
that process like a lot a lot easier.
You can do most of it directly from here
and it lets you know like when things
are done. So you don't actually have to
do a lot from the Twe console at all. Um
anyway, so
um I let me show you the back end. So
there is
a handler function. There we go.
Function handlers. So um you can either
implement tools
uh locally as a JSON schema and we can
we can try that really quick. So this is
the real time playground and I can say
like you know make
a function to you know get the answer to
answers to
everything no params maybe one
param. Okay, so it gave it gave us this
nice little
uh nice little function and we can just
paste it in
here, save
it, and cool. So now we have this get
universe answers and I can save this
configuration and call the phone
number. So, let's
see.
Hello.
Hello. Okay, this is why I love them.
Let me let me try once
more. Okay, let's go tool. Paste this.
Save changes. Save
config.
[Music]
Um,
hello.
Hello. I don't think it's
happy. Is someone else? No, I didn't
show the number. Hello. Okay, it's not
working. That's fine. Sort of expected
it. Um, essentially what you can do like
when you when you use this, um, it's
cool because these tools you can either
specify local ones with schema and they
appear here or you can define them in
the back end. Um, so if you define them
in the back end, you can actually give
like code to execute. Um, if not,
they'll just show up here. Uh, and you
can enter in like what the response will
be uh, like a mock response. Um, but you
can also like set up backend functions
that will actually get handled in the
back end. Uh the sample one is like a
real implemented get weather one but as
you can see there's like it's pretty
straightforward to implement like the 01
one. Now the main difference between the
real time API here and like what we were
doing before is the real time API does
actually allow asynchronous functions
natively. So you can the model can call
a function um get no response and you
can keep talking with the model um until
a response is back. So that that is
behavior that like we specifically had
to teach the real-time models because
unlike a chat conversation, you can't
really enforce um like you can't really
halt the whole conversation until the
functioning response comes back. So, we
had to do that for for for launch um
because originally when we hadn't done
that, you know, we hadn't ever shown it
how to do asynchronous functions and so
it just couldn't couldn't handle them
correctly. Anyway, sadly, uh demo didn't
quite work. Maybe I can try this one
more time. We'll see. Third time's a
charm.
Hello.
Hello. No. Okay, great. Anyway,
um I believe that is most of what I
wanted to cover today.
Um, I'm going to play with this hyper
unsafe function making agent a bit, but
um, yeah, thank you all for coming. I'll
hang around for questions for a bit if
anyone has any. Otherwise, I think we're
ending a little bit early. Um, like I
said, yeah, mo most of you can can hang
out or or leave as you please. Um, but
I'll maybe I'll call it wrapped up here.
Um, maybe what we can do is if you're
interested, you can stay and like hack
on some of the stuff that you saw. I'm
happy to hang around uh and answer
questions as well. So, thank you all for
coming. Uh, hope you hope you got
something out of this.
Um, the
new uh to help in
sports. Uh
otherwise, I guess you can share. I'm
sharing a little bit in case people have
questions.
I'm actually going to dump this, but
this may be a really bad idea, but um
here you go. Here's the code for the
super unsafe self like tool writing
agent.
And I'm probably going to stop sharing
my
screen. Um, yeah, I can I can I can
share the repo and the slides. There's
not a lot on the slides, but yeah, I'm
happy to happy to share them after.